[Musique]
réduire vos heures de travail passées à
la semaine de quatre jours tout en
conservant le même salaire est ce que ça
vous tente en tout cas c'est le sujet de
notre ca du vendredi ce soir avec tania
saba de l'école de relations
industrielles de l'université de
montréal et david anfossi chef de studio
chez idof montréal à vous de bonsoir
bonsoir alors david anfossi d'abord
votre entreprise de jeux vidéo high
dolls a annoncé en octobre dernier que
tous les employés à sherbrooke à
montréal cinq cents personnes environ
vont passer à la semaine de quatre jours
de travail quelles sont leurs conditions
tout à fait donc c'est un long processus
mais on est finalement à cette
transition où effectivement on va avoir
une semaine de quatre jours donc 32
heures parce que l'on ne parle pas de
condenser 40 heures en quatre jours
c'est pas le but 32' 20 heures
exactement avec une troisième journée de
repos qui va être le vendredi et tout
ceci vient avec une un programme
d'amélioration de notre efficience et
pourquoi vous faites ça
plusieurs raisons il ya une démarche
itérative
on n'est pas passés de 40 heures 40
heures à 32 eur on est depuis à peu près
un an à 36 heures déjà pour re tester
justement comment on peux se réorganiser
justement mais il ya un c'est une simple
adaptation j'allais diva à notre nouveau
contexte notre nouvelle réalité qui est
le travail à distance dans un contexte
de pandémie
donc on s'est aperçu que la frontière
entre le travail et la vie privée
devenue de plus en plus floue ouais et
c'était notre devoir à nous en tant que
qu'écosystème organisation de travailler
ensemble pour voir comment on pouvait
prendre soin de nous santé mentale santé
physique prendre soin de notre famille
et de nos proches aussi d'accord tania
saba vous vous êtes peut-être un peu
sceptique face à la semaine de quatre
jours dites nous pourquoi
mais j'ai pas dire sceptiques me retirer
il ya comme tout changement important il
ya les bonnes choses que l'on voit mais
il ya également des risques je trouve
qu'on s'en va tout à fait dans le bon
sens parce que avec une semaine de
quatre jours qui en fait une réduction
des heures de travail parce que ce n'est
pas une compression comme l'a bien
mentionné monsieur anfossi ben ça va
s'en va dans le sens de la
réappropriation du temps exactement ce à
quoi on aspire on a bien vu si des
personnes ont été en jouer l'engouement
si vous voulez du travail à distance
c'est justement cette question de
réappropriation du temps de travail
pourquoi pas c'est le modèle de passer
dix heures à se déplacer à l'est son
travail est peut-être en train d'être de
devenir évolue donc je découvrais tout
d'accord
je suis d'accord je suis cependant mon
scepticisme et autour des risques
mais encore une fois de ce que j'entends
de monsieur aussi quand même on a pris
en considération l'importance de revoir
le travail de revoir les systèmes
d'emploi parce que ce qu'on a
expérimenté à travers le télétravail
c'est beaucoup et on transpose ce qu'on
faisait avant et on le fait à nouveau et
c'est là où ça ne marche pas il ya des
technologies nouvelles mais où les
utilise pas toujours à bon escient on a
vu que les heures de réunions ont
beaucoup augmenté que les la difficulté
aussi parfois des échanges et est rendu
plus difficile mais c'est pas la faute
des technologies des technologies sont
là c'est la façon comment on les utilise
alors probablement ici dans un milieu de
technologie peut-être qu'on fera
attention justement à la façon
d'utiliser les technologies pour
effectivement rendre le travail plus
productif et pouvoir justement à faire
l'économie de cette est ce que est ce
que une fois si vous auriez pu gagner 20
% de productivité en implantant les
mêmes changements mais sans réduire la
semaine de vos employés
très bonne question on se les poser
collectivement qui sommes à un point sur
lequel j'aimerais beaucoup insisté c'est
que cette initiative en fait c'est une
initiative collective en est on des
thunes pas ce que j'appelle un
écosystème chez eidos où on travaille
tous ensemble le système pi rangueil les
années 70 est révolu chez nous toutes
les décisions comment s'organise la
culture organisationnelle est vraiment
décidée de façon collective donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
collective
et on s'est posé la question mais le but
par exemple pour développer un jeu c'est
cinq ans de travail d'efforts pour 200
250 personnes c'est un marathon
aujourd'hui comme madame le disait très
bien on est interrompu en tout temps
parce qu'on peut être rejoint par une
meute cellulaire notre notre laptop par
téléphone et ses
messages textes ça on finit plus donc
comment gère la communication le partage
d'informations comment gère l'un
travaille sur la longue durée c'est
vraiment des critères qui ont été de
super important pour nous donc juste
gagner en efficience ce n'est pas la
solution il faut gérer notre énergie
notre santé mentale oui et en ce faisant
on va avoir de meilleurs résultats en
termes de performance studio mais aussi
des dossiers de sienne en pleine santé
ok vous avez donc choisi ça après une
longue réflexion nous dit vous madame ça
va être créé des meilleures idées que la
semaine de quatre jours
il y as certainement la semaine de
quatre jours fait en sorte que on
revient dans les espaces de travail
qu'on veut fort probablement que toutes
les relations qui se font se font donc
au travail et je pense que c'est une
façon d'allier les deux donc en même
temps de se dire ok moins d'heures on
sait que la cette réappropriation du
temps aussi dans des secteurs qui
demande beaucoup de créativité c'est une
bonne chose parce que la personne ne
peut pas juste être créatif de 8h à 10h
ou deux on est créatif on y pense et
quand on libère les personnes mais c'est
sûr que l on le temps même de penser et
d'être plus en forme pour venir puissent
faire leur travail les autres formes
mais écoutez on l'a expérimenté le
travail à distance donc peut-être garder
c'est la délocalisation le fait de
pouvoir le faire ailleurs aussi mais ça
reprend les mêmes principes que travail
par exemple de quatre jours c'est encore
une fois de revoir le système d'emploi
lors voir comment le travail est
organisée qui moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'on s'en va dans ce sens
lâche honnêtement ça fait 40 ans qu'on
attend la société de loisirs ça fait 40
ans comment sa valeur que le travail on
arrive enfin
on arrive enfin sam adams ah bah ouais
j'en suis convaincu oui moi je pense que
oui on commence à nous rendre là mais ce
sont aussi les difficultés qui ont été
vécues en termes de bien-être de santé
mentale de congés de maladie qui sont
aussi très nombreux dans les milieux de
travail oui on est rendu là et encore
une fois une expérimentation nous a
permis de le faire il faut aller dans ce
sens la seule difficulté le risque c'est
qu'il faut expérimenter
corriger puis ensuite parce qu'on est
dans les normes nouveau système que vous
faites le faire une fois ci dans le fond
exactement puis que je parlais
d'écosystèmes on est vraiment un
écosystème agile je faisais souvent la
comparaison avec des cellules qui sont
capables de ce2 ce2 s'allier de se
mettre ensemble en fonction du contexte
et des besoins donc contexte c'est tout
ce qui peut arriver de l'extérieur aussi
bien que ce qui se passe dans notre
industrie propre donc l'homme en transit
sienne c'est déjà le cas on l'a fait 36
heures leur nez à 32 heures qui en
apprend il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent moins bien d'autres qui
fonctionne bien qui ça se fait dans deux
ans on bascule à un autre modèle on
évolue déjà vers quelque chose d'autre
donc il faut apprendre en permanence
qu'on a fait avec la pandémie qu on a
appris de la pandémie puis on s'est
adapté avec le 4 jours semaine mais ça
peut évoluer vers d'autres choses en
tout cas vous n'êtes pas seul parce que
d'autres entreprises qui adoptent la
semaine de quatre jours cela dit ça
s'applique certainement pas tous les
secteurs on va poursuivre la discussion
et la réflexion là dessus prochainement
tania saba merci d'avedon fois-ci merci
beaucoup
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi